as russia continues its assault on
ukraine calls for action from the
international community grow louder with
debate raging on everything from the
effectiveness of sanctions to whether
nato's involvement with ukraine
contributed to tensions with moscow and
fears that direct action by nato could
translate into war across europe
but can anything deter putin and what
would a long war mean not just for the
people of ukraine but for russian
citizens as well that's our discussion
this week on an upfront special
joining me to discuss the latest on
ukraine are dr stephanie bapst former
deputy assistant secretary general of
nato dr eugenia albats editor-in-chief
of russia's the new times magazine and
dr agne rodriguez a senior fellow at the
atlantic council and author of the book
beyond crimea the new russian empire
thank you all for joining me uh evgeny
let me start with you you've covered the
kremlin for decades so you understand
better than most people uh how they make
decisions we've seen weeks of warnings
from the west about an imminent invasion
of ukraine uh troop build up along the
border and of course diplomatic efforts
to avoid the outcome that we're seeing
today
uh
in your view
was war
inevitable
you know
obviously i'm not in the business of
reading the crystal ball
i'm just a journalist but i do think
that putin made his mind
pretty much uh last autumn
and when she realized uh that he was
unable to force the west to become to
where
to provide him with
the kind of
world international arrangements that he
wanted it is to say that he wanted to
divide
the world or into spheres of influence
and
assigned to russia all the former
uh church republic
when she realized that she was not going
to do that she decided to start the war
he seemed to be uh following the advice
of very particular sets of advisers
particularly the most
hawkish uh wing of his security council
he doesn't have to follow advisors of
any hawkish
members of his security council because
he himself
a hardline politician
with distrust of the west
he uh he's a graduate of the
soviet union's wall supremacy
institution the kgb
and these the kind of institution which
uh institutional culture and
organizational culture
always
has been based on
violence
so i would say that for putin is just
natural
if she couldn't get what she wanted to
get she waited and then she decided to
give by force you know he just he wants
to have the kind of order the kind of
international order that stalin uh
agreed to have with russell and
churchill that's what you and she wants
to shoot himself as a nowadays stalin
stephanie in recent months russia has
repeatedly pointed the finger at nato uh
some have even argued that nato is at
least partially responsible
for the outbreak of war arguing that its
expansion in the early 2000s to include
uh former soviet countries uh is at the
root of today's crisis would you agree
with that assessment
no uh unsurprisingly i i don't agree
with that assessment
let me let me say first of all i mean
that we do have principles um global
principles including
uh the free choice
of countries to determine their own
security arrangements nato didn't go
around shopping and ask people to join
it was vice versa
countries like lithuania estonia the
czech republic poland all these
countries really sought
to become
a member of nato because they thought it
was best for their own uh countries and
they took a free and deliberate choice
um that's number one but number two i
would like to stress i also recall
vividly
because back then i i was there
when we signed
the strategic partnership with russia
that was back in 1997
and we established a joint permanent
council so we we gave
russia
really quite a bit of say if i can say
so on nato issues and we invited russia
to work with us jointly and over
almost 15 years we worked with russia um
it's
now almost unthinkable i mean to recall
but i was there i was part of it and i
still vividly recall
the many many issues on which we work
with russia
and nato has never done anything wrong
in terms of suggesting to russia that we
would
reduce their or ignore their legitimate
concerns by contrast we invited them to
be with us to partner with them
stephanie there are some people who
would say i agree with everything you're
saying but in the absence of nato putin
doesn't have the pretext
that there would not have been an
invasion
absent the pretext of nato and his
concerns around nato what do you make of
that
well i suggest it's all part of putin's
narrative uh
he tried very hard and still is trying i
mean to basically roll back history and
interpret everything which i'm talking
about the past 20 years as something
which ultimately constitutes a threat
towards russia
so this is very much a narrative and
reactions in allied countries basically
reactions around the world now make very
clear that we don't buy into this
narrative we don't want to live in a
world which is divided by spheres of
inferences and we go don't want to go
back as eugenia has said to iyalta's
style a
power play i mean between the big powers
so um i'm afraid to say putin has
miscalculated a lot
given that uh in his speech announcing
the offensive into ukraine putin also
said the operation aim to de-nazify the
country
in your view is the invasion
again really about nato or is nato just
a pretext
you know nato is absolutely just a
pretext there are many other pretexts
that putin has used i mean again
denatification i mean
extraordinary extraordinary statement
completely detached from reality um
president zelinski himself is jewish so
it's very difficult to make that
argument i mean putin has made other
arguments that ukraine is a brotherly
nation a brotherly slavic nation so
therefore they're gonna you know invade
it whether ukraine likes it or not um to
support and help their brotherly nation
so i think uh there are many narratives
that putin has tried playing out over
the course of this time and really since
um
um since 2014 since the first invasion
of crimea since the creation of
separatist regions in luhansk and
donetsk at the time the pretext was that
the russian language speakers in ukraine
were being discriminated against so
therefore he's going to go in and help
them
there's been many presets but the end of
the day i think this is really for him
a project of personal ambition
to try to re-establish russia's
influence and control over the
post-soviet space uh he
president putin has stated many times
that um the fall of the soviet union was
the greatest catastrophe
geopolitical disaster of the 20th
century so this is i think something he
wants to reverse and have this as his
legacy
as president of russia
afghani nato was formed in 1949 uh
during the cold war primarily
to counter potential soviet threats uh
does the organization's very existence
still hinge upon a certain kind of
tension
or the threat of war from russia
when putin became the president back in
2000
one of his first moves was he said that
he would like to join if he would like
russia to join nato
so at the very beginning of his
presidency there was no talk about
any threat from the side of the north
atlantic future organization
no it's all peter
we can believe
that
[Music]
russia and you know he as a russian
the right to decide which nation has
full rights of sovereignty and which
nations don't
so he decided that ukraine doesn't have
uh
error
doesn't have this sovereign right to
decide
uh who to uh alive with
and that's
that's it
i think that it's
it's so
misleading to keep talking about nato
threat look
the russian propaganda machine no longer
talks about nato russian propaganda
machine now tells to russian citizens
that
russia had to start this preemptive war
in order to prevent
ukraine
from developing its own nuclear weapons
stephanie the war has put the question
of uh nato membership for ukraine into
conversation once again it's on the
table once more uh despite having been
repeatedly dismissed in the past
why has the idea of ukraine as a nato
member always seemed so unlikely
well a bit like the european union nato
has a key
for new members so it is not just i mean
that we look at photos pictures and
listen to nice
speeches
we want to make sure nato wants to make
sure
that any new um country
accessing nato can actually make
um a contribution can
bring to the table
net uh military capabilities uh shares
uh the same values doesn't have any type
of territorial or other related conflict
i'm afraid to say it never actually met
the criteria um there were still and
there was still quite um some work to do
for the ukrainians um
on on their side so that's more or less
i mean the procedural aspect but above
all there is a political aspect
and if there's
one thing that i criticize uh
when looking at my
my former employer i think the decision
taken back at the bucharest summit in
2008 was not helpful because it left
georgia and ukraine with this ambiguity
it was agreed because there was no
agreement that we would invite ukraine
as well as georgia and to become member
at some point but we didn't specify a
date and that left to countries in limbo
i thought strategically speaking
politically speaking that was not
helpful neither for nato's course nor
for the course of the two countries
concerned agni another thing that
creates difficulty is this question of
energy independence
uh
right now europe plans to reduce its
dependence on russia uh and that
is perceived by moscow as a threat uh
you yourself have called for more
sanctions on russia's nord stream ii
pipeline the natural gas pipeline that
would double russia's natural gas
exports to europe uh via germany
uh in your view has europe's energy
dependence uh on russia emboldened putin
absolutely and i think uh this energy
dependence also was one of the reasons
putin miscalculated with this invasion
but if you
look at europe today the reality is it's
at least about a third dependent on
russian gas imports
fortunately with
the globalization of the gas markets and
the united states becoming a major gas
producer and lng exporter there are more
options for european importing states
but nonetheless today they remain highly
dependent and north stream two is a
pipeline that had a big impact on the
way this crisis unfolded because the
north stream two pipeline directly from
russia to germany once it was completed
and completed today it's not certified
and not operational and hopefully it
won't become so but once it was
completed it allowed
russia to bypass the ukrainian gas
pipeline system which was one of the
primary means of sending gas from russia
to europe and now that there's an
alternative route um there was
essentially this created a green light
for putin's government
to invade ukraine and to if
damaged that pipeline in the process if
you know there was nothing holding it
back from outright war and damaging that
pipeline system because there was a
belief that now they'll have an
alternative pipeline system so this um
gas dependence uh oil dependence
really has it direct links with this
current war in ukraine
uh let's talk a bit about sanctions uh
evgenia there's been a lot of debate
over the impact of sanctions on russia
many have expressed concern that the
effects of sanctions are more likely to
be felt by ordinary russian citizens
rather than by
the powerful by the state itself uh are
sanctions the right choice
i'm not sure that i want to answer this
question because
as a political scientist i would say yes
i think that these harsh sanctions
are going to
um
to
create some pressure
with kremlin and over putin and may lead
to the split of daily
and change of the regime
however the kind of the sanctions that
have been have been imposed on russia
they affect
a lot of my fellow
citizens
we just
uh yesterday before yesterday we woke up
in
in a totally new world and it's totally
new country
and it doesn't look nice
in fact you know life looks ugly
a lot of uh fellow banks and phones now
people are trying to withdraw
uh high currency
uh dollars and euros and they emitting
difficulty of doing this they're already
not clear how russians are going to
where russians are going to buy their
cars or how they're going to
um
to conduct maintains of
their automobiles there are a hell of a
lot of problems that
we're going to face pretty soon
however i hate to talk about that
because i feel so ashamed
about what my country
is doing doing right now
to the neighboring country to ukraine i
see teachers from the web and i know
that uh
hundreds and thousands of queens are
dying
each day
or you know or
they get wounded
the beautiful city i traveled around
ukraine time and again i know this
country will i love this country in fact
my grandma
family was from ukraine
and i see
what russian
russian
missiles and russian bombs are doing to
heartgive to kiev
to [ __ ]
to marijuana and i'm terrified
that this is done
by the army which i as a taxpayer as a
citizen of the russian federation
i pay for that
and that makes me sick
ashamed
and you know
and
no sanctions are good enough
if uh putin and his people
are not going to be punished
for the kind of stuff that they did to
that they have been doing to ukraine and
to europe in general listen
we in europe we found ourselves in 1939
1939 that was the year when the world
war ii started
i couldn't believe that i live in the
country which lost 27 million people
to the world war two
and this very country where each piece
of land is somebody's great
this country started to war and killing
people
right now
21st century europe it's just impossible
to comprehend
stephanie earlier this week
switzerland announced that it would
freeze russian-held financial assets uh
in the country totaling more than 11
billion dollars it's a big number uh
that's according to the new york times
uh that's a rather shocking move given
switzerland's long history
of neutrality what what does that kind
of move tell us
it tells me that the global community is
really
rallying around one point uh which is to
to really express their opposition
their frustration their anger they
outburst uh with regard to what's
ongoing in in ukraine even smaller
countries neutral countries like
switzerland you mentioned have joined
the chorus i
i must admit i feel a little bit um
ambivalent about it on one hand i think
it's absolutely good and important that
the international community comes
together from various sectors
countries tech sectors sports cultures
you name it to express
their opposition but the more we do it
the more we do it the more i fear i mean
we corner president putin
considerably and if we were to put
ourselves into his shoes and consider
policy options what is it i mean that
can actually um how can move forward
what is this exit strategy
i feel i mean that we ourselves need to
also get
smarter and develop a strategy how to
actually manage such a putin regime
under
global pressure
i think that's the question which is on
the table now for policy makers across
the board how do we manage that agnia
i'm thinking about what eugenia says
about the kind of enormity of the moment
she's making comparisons to 1939.
uh
the
push that stephanie's talking about from
the global community is part of the
response to this moment what do you see
as the proper global response the proper
type of pressure switzerland gives one
model of it but what do you see as the
kind of broader response that you would
expect from the global community
well one specific thing i would like to
see particularly in europe is
and it's going to be difficult i
understand but it's a move that europe
will have to make
at some point it's essentially
sanctioning russian sources of energy
russian oil and gas
it's um
again not easy to achieve because europe
is dependent on this but there are
global markets um they may have to pay
more but if you look at it today
essentially the money that europe spends
or sends to russia for oil and gas
imports this is essentially the russian
military budget so if you want to cut
off the russian military budget one of
the primary things you could do is
really start to get serious and start
sanctioning russian oil and gas
um i think first with stopping the north
stream two pipeline um even stopping the
operations of north stream one pipeline
and i think germany in this last week
has really had an epiphany they've
really started re-examining their
policies um germany is europe's largest
gas market um largest client of gasprom
so the moves they make will have a big
difference and i'm also seeing changes
in turkey as well
um turkey is the second largest market
for gas prom in the in within the
european context
and
with the decision of president erdogan
to close the boss forest straits to
russian
military ship movement is a step in the
positive direction
uh evgeny we've seen thousands of
russians marching in anti-war
protests we've even seen
some unexpected high profile figures
inside of russia speaking out against
the war is
there any dissent in your view within
putin's inner circle
or even within his government for what's
happening right now
i have no doubt that there are people
who are strongly opposed the war
especially those
in the on the economic on the financial
side of the russian government
because basically russian economy will
be in pieces in the matter of several
one
so the situation is extremely difficult
and
uh you know russian hard currency
reserve
frozen so central bank is unable to
interfere
therefore
russian currency lost 30 percent of its
value it means that prices for all goods
food or whatever commodities
will go significantly up and those who
were poor will become much much poorer
poor
russian
young people they are leaving the
country are nasty they're just running
outside the country russian rich people
russian middle class they're also
everybody is trying to find way to get
out of
russia
6 000 people were detained
as they took part in different protests
across the country
my uh
publication the new times
uh got blocked
because uh you know russian government
believes that we shouldn't use the word
war
or uh there are no war no invasion
no offense of federation it's just some
uh
some uh
operation that putin conducts against uh
neighboring country
uh
the only independent radio station left
ahuma
also was
taken down by the russian government the
only independent tv channel
tv reign
was
taken down
by the russian government as well it's
editing chief and the majority of
reporters
decided to leave the country i mean it
is a real disaster for uh for my country
indeed and we'll continue to cover this
uh every step of the way
uh stephanie evgenia uh agnea thank you
so much for joining me on upfront
that's our show up front we'll be back
next week
you